the 26 letters of the Latin alphabet
handed down to us from ancient Rome and
fitted albeit imperfectly to our English
tongue wait not so fast that's wrong
this was the Latin alphabet the rest of
these were just crafted by some clever
old-school modders yes it's true your
G's JS use double use and wise don't
have the ancient pedigree of the rest of
your alphabet but what they lack in
antiquity they more than make up for in
scrappiness this is their story
G was the first to emerge long ago Greek
guff its way to Italy and turn into
Latin si but in early Latin the SI
actually stood for the sound good and
the sound cook we're still the one
letter you might think could straighten
things out here between cun good let us
differentiate them that valiant K well
that was going out of fashion but si was
still hanging on coming and going along
tilling was that's sensible they could
tell you all about how these two velar
stops actually share most of their
features and they just differ in one
little thing
voicing but to everyday Romans that's
little consolation the difference was
confusing and dangerous I mean does this
say he's milking it or does it mean let
him beat it up who knows I mean it's all
seized all seized calm down and open the
door because here enters spurious carve
alias ruga a former slave that ran his
own private school twenty-two hundred
years ago frustrated with this two-faced
C and unable to even write his own name
clearly the story goes that he tacked on
an extra stroke creating a new G and
forever setting C apart from G an
amazing stroke of genius
well if seek and have a companion why
can't you well the only you around was
actually V from older Greek oops salon
more on that in a second Greek words
staged a fashionable Latin comeback a
little after the birth of G and educated
writers wanted a fancy way to write this
strange Greek you with it's very
unromantic in a new loop salon a second
hoop salon a Greek even it today in
English Greek words like
still have that new letter a letter
missing from plain old Latin words
tweaking C's and borrowing wises
lightweight compared to what comes next
the Middle Ages saw the rise of a new
letter I with a tail below it what was
originally a different look not a
different letter tailed I gave medieval
European language is a way to set je
apart from I and that's important
because if we roll this story back to
the Romans we see an overburden letter I
that had to play both roles take the
Latin word for young just take it that
first I was a yes sound but the last
one's the vowel e similar enough but
linguistically that means eyes trying
its hardest to be both a vowel E and a
consonant yeah add in our swishy tail
and this serif I'd J comes to the rescue
as R consonant leaving I just as a vowel
so une s-- but that's not good enough
there's another confusing letter hiding
in that word and it's the next one on
our change list like I the Latin letter
V covers two sounds a vowel ooh and a
consonant wah what we'd call W and
that's why we like you when East because
it has both of them in a row never fear
we can sort this out just round out the
bottom of that V and what do you know
it's the value array but this change
actually lingered for centuries in older
manuscripts the U is still used as a
variant of V for both V and
boo eventually after a long sell by the
end of the 1700s the two were treated as
two totally different letters finally
we've arrived so we have a better way to
write you a nice but listen to old
Cicero's pronunciation of that V what he
says wha so I glossed over that change
when I said that V ended up standing for
both of uh and ooh but early on that
what pronunciation shifted to something
pretty close to but not exactly like our
V so by the time little Henry the eighth
was studying his Latin that V had long
been a V seriously Henry fine yes this
book is yours have it well speaking of
Englishmen when early Germanic languages
like Old English dress themselves in the
Latin alphabet they asked about their
newfound garb hey where's the letter
form I was sound
and it didn't answer them back since
it's an inanimate metaphor but dramatic
speakers had already learned to get what
they want when Rome was being
withholding no exception here they
cobbled together a new letter of their
own by taking that V and putting it next
to another V don't forget though that V
and u were still two peas in a pod at
the time each one useful for making van
ooh sounds meaning you could write this
new letter as a double V or a double u
but here's where we should jump off the
hamster wheel of history because
eventually that German will starts to
turn into von its own just like the
Latin V before it oh history really like
to keep your fingers on that replay
button don't you I'd love to go on and
compare other alphabets and talk about
how or even if each individual European
language adopted these changes or didn't
or made decisions of its own think about
how to this day the Irish alphabet makes
none of these distinctions except C and
G but this is a good place to wrap up
between last time with the uppercase
lowercase stuff in these modded letters
I think you can see that well you might
think your alphabets been aging and
evolving since time immemorial in some
very real ways it's not as old as you
think